in the depths of Hara we will always
find hope in the men and women who risk
their lives for ours we pray for the
recovery of the injured and those
injured officers who so bravely threw
themselves into danger when duty called
and we grieve the loss of the
law-enforcement personnel who were
killed in this vicious attack here on
earth we are blessed to be surrounded by
heroes all right that was President
Trump raising first responders in the
wake of the worst mass shooting in US
history now earlier this week the Vegas
police department released body cam
footage from officers risking their
lives rushing toward the scene of the
shooting just take a small look at the
small sampling of what these officers do
every single day
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey they're shooting right at us guys
everybody stay down stay down horse it
out and joining us now Las Vegas
metropolitan police officer Brady cook
he was shot Sunday night it was just the
second day on the job
also joining us as officer cooks partner
officer Josh Hanes guys good to see
officer cook I guess that's one way of
saying welcome to the force we're glad
you here baptism by fire I know you you
police officers know the risk I'm sure
you and your family did not expect that
no I didn't expect it but it's what I
signed up for when stuff goes down I
want to be there to face evil and
protect the good innocent people that
need it yeah you know tell I know it's
an amazing thing and I've had a chance
over the years I interviewed a lot of
military guys I I spoke with a couple of
the people that were shot in the
hospital yesterday and described the
scene the situation what you were doing
when you got shot what you felt and take
us from there until you got to the
hospital and the nature of your injury
well we responded to the active shooter
call we didn't at first we had no idea
where the shooting was coming from we
got reports that it was coming from in
the festival then outside the festival
then actually at the Mandalay Bay so we
responded to the call down in Las Vegas
Boulevard
we got all the vehicle there was already
some patrol cars there we parked we took
cover we were just we got out in a rain
of gunfire all you could see around us
was the samantha's pop pop pop pop pop
but the just rounds hitting the ground
we took some cover behind the patrol
cars we actually drew the fire off of
the crowd so that other people could get
out and in the midst of all that trying
to find the gunfire I end up getting hit
and uh that was a party what you gave me
and we got out there we ran down Las
Vegas Boulevard he the shooter traced us
I don't know how we didn't get shot more
he was tracing us with gunfire
he ended up ripping my shirt off to see
where I was hit
we ended up keep going and getting a
patrol car stealing a patrol car and he
rushed me to the hospital where did you
get hit and what did it feel like when I
got hit I went in though it was kind of
weird the whole shooting being in a
random gunfire I wasn't scared at all I
know the gentleman going I didn't even
feel the gunshot hit me I just noticed
my arm turn into a noodle I went
completely limp and I just saw blood
gushing everywhere well you know it's
amazing how many people tell me they
didn't even know because of the
environment the adrenaline as you say
they don't even feel to get hit but then
they look and they're like wow what
happened here
officer Haynes tell us what happened on
your end you know when that uh when that
shooting took place we were doing a foot
patrol halfway up the strip in a
different areas so we we traveled down
the strip about a mile rolling code
which means you know lights and sirens
whipping through the traffic just to get
there and when we arrived you know my
first thought was to make sure that we
did take cover we didn't know where the
rounds were coming from we actually
thought that it was two shooters at the
time one inside the route 91 concert and
then one outside at Mandalay Bay and by
the time we realized exactly where the
rounds were coming from you know the
rounds were coming down like raindrops
there was so many impact points that all
we could do was try to hunker down at
one point you know Brady asked me hey
where are the rounds coming from and
almost immediately thereafter that's
when he was hit and at that point you
know my only concern was to make sure
that he got the care he needed because
there was no way we could bring medical
into that that range of fire for the
shooter when you saw we had injury
officer Haynes when you saw the injury
and he said his arm felt like a noodle
and and you're looking at it how bad did
you think it was and how nervous were
you just looking at it you know
initially I
I saw the initial impact and I thought
it wasn't harm when I when I stripped
his shirt and I pulled his vest off I
could see two impact points there was
one under the arm and then it looked
like there was a second one going
through the chest I tried you know the
intention was to put a tourniquet on his
arm but I realized that time was an
issue because of that second bullet
wound I was concerned that he had a lung
injury and at that point but it was it
was a matter of minutes so you know the
tourniquet was not an option anymore and
I knew I just had to get him to to a
trauma center good for you
officer cook an amazing story we're glad
you're safe we wish you a speedy speedy
recovery and officer Haynes thank you
for what you did for your partner and
I'm what you both do was a city of Vegas
every night thank you both thank you sir